if you were scrolling on Instagram this
holiday season you most likely saw this
pic wait here of Drake and Jennifer loop
I saw it it sparked the hashtag Dre low
and added even more speculation of the
romance rumors surrounding the pair yeah
since then they've been seen multiple
times together they got all teenage
dreamy dancing together at a prom themed
party in Las Vegas and we're caught
kissing on her oh and then there was
that New Year's Eve remember when JLo
canceled her 1 million dollar gig in
Miami so she could spend more time with
family yeah I remember what Drake is a
long-lost cousin Paul it looks like she
had plans to see Drake perform in Las
Vegas you can see her right there in
this video and she was even photographed
wearing his necklace now this has us all
asking a whole lot of questions first
off what happened to Drake and Rihanna
yeah good question well since Dre lo
posted that photo together Rihanna's
unfollowed Jen on Instagram and sources
at drake's new year's eve bash say that
when his duet with Rihanna work starters
playing he quickly told the DJ to switch
the track call you quote an old violet
dude kill it you're killing me bro and
while many believe that Drake is feeling
his new vibe others think this is well
fake love ya any insider tells page six
that their relationship is just to
publicize their new music cinnamon if
they were really dating they'd be way
more private about sochi